[Music]
hey and uh
welcome back after lunch it's been a
great conference so far it's been great
to be here
my name is david smith i'm a cloud
advocate with microsoft
so basically that means i'm microsoft's
connection with the r community
so if there's anything you would like me
to communicate back to the development
teams back in redmond just have a chat
with me and i'll pass that on
but today i would like to talk to you
about machine learning operations
and that's the process of efficiently
and reliably
building machine learning models at
scale we call it mlaps
it's a relatively new term you might see
it being related to something you're
more familiar
with which is devops and devops itself i
don't have time to get into all the
details of that but
a definition that i like uh which comes
from one of my colleagues at microsoft
is that devops is the union of people
process and products to enable the
continuous delivery of
value to your end users and note that
word value there we're not talking about
software
we're not looking at applications we're
talking about value in general
so it seems like it's something that we
could also apply to machine learning in
the same way that it's traditionally
applied
to regular applications
so what devops gives us is a nice
process
for delivering applications in general
we plan
we develop and test those applications
we release them into production
and once they're in production we're not
done because in production we monitor
and learn
from our users experiences with those
applications and go through that entire
cycle again
and so the question that i want to ask
here is
can we apply a similar process to
devops for building applications to
building machine learning models
with r in particular in this case and i
don't know about you but
at least in my experience when working
with machine learning models
it's a little bit different than
building applications with
with regular programming languages you
know you start with some data
you might try a model you might try
another model
you'll evaluate the results you decide
that you might need some more data you
might need a different model
it's a very iterative process
but at the end of that process what you
get
is a model that you'd like to put into
production and you
throw it over the wall to the
engineering team to do something with it
at least that was my experience
up until relatively recently i don't
know if it was yours as well but you can
see
that this is kind of very different to
the modern way
of building applications with continuous
integration and continuous delivery
so can we get to that stage with machine
learning
and i think one of the ways that we can
think about that
is to have a look at some of the
differences between traditional
development processes
devops and machine learning building
mlops
now in both cases we're working with
files
you know that source code you know it
might be c plus or
net files on the regular application
side of things but with machine learning
we're also working with
other artifacts things like data files
there's a whole thread i could go down
to get goku down in at this point about
thinking about
what does it mean to have a 55 a
gigabyte
data file that you're analysis analyzing
and putting that into get
short don't do that but lots of issues
around managing data that don't come up
in traditional development processes
same things if you're working with
notebooks or rmd documents
or markdown documents how do we deal
with those and how do they manage
in source code control systems
a good practice when building
applications is rather than managing
infrastructure directly by pointing and
clicking in in consoles and terminals
is to manage that infrastructure with
commands in code and those same
principles
apply on the machine learning side as
well with an additional wrinkle
that we often have to manage
environments think for in the er
case managing the the packages and the
package
versions that need to exist for your r
model to run in a reliable fashion so we
want to be able to manage those
as code as well i touched a little bit
about those issues of working with
source code control systems
those also apply in the machine learning
operations scenario
but there are other things we need to
track changes in as well not just the
source code
we also want to track out track changes
in our experiments
and by that i mean as we try out
different types of models perhaps
different transformations of our data
we're looking for some kind of outcome
perhaps the model with the best accuracy
and we'd like to be able to track
that as well in a reproducible way so
that we can always go back to prior
experiments if that
determined that we end up using that one
instead
and i've mentioned already this issue
about managing data sets in source code
when we're building applications in a
devops environments typically we're
building
binary executables those builds might
take minutes maybe hours you know that's
kind of the
the typical limit for most types of
applications
you're typically building on sort of
commodity computing infrastructure
but on the machine learning side rather
than building
in addition to building executables
rather we're building the models we're
training the models to become part of
those executables
and that model training especially in in
sort of deep learning type of
environments
could likely take hours might well take
days i've seen examples where model
training takes months
um and so how do we put that into a
traditional devops type of environment
and also how do we incorporate the
exotic computing environments like the
gpu computing environments that we need
for deep learning
when it comes to version control version
management when we're booting
applications we like to give
versions um to the versions the the
applications that we build and release
on the machine learning side we would
like to assign versions to models so we
can track when we change a model
and then go back to the underlying data
and code
that that that created that model and do
so
reproducibly and another sort of
side branch that i could go into for
hours is this whole concept of
tests when it comes to machine learning
as opposed to
developing applications and the
application size tests are fairly
deterministic
did it break did it cause an error did
it give the right response
but in machine learning tests tend to be
a bit more probabilistic
you know think of the question of is
this a picture of a cat
that's not so much of a yes or no type
question it's more of a probabilistic
thing that we need to determine and so
the way we do testing is different
i can't go into all of these topics
today but i'm just going to touch on a
few of them but i just wanted to give
you this
as just an illustration that there are
quite a few differences in my opinion
between machine learning operations and
traditional devops
and we need to incorporate those
differences into any process that we're
using
when we build applications with machine
learning
now microsoft has an application to help
with that
it's called the applica azure machine
learning service
it's based on a process that we
developed internally for building the
machine learning models that we have in
things like
bing and xbox and all sorts of other
applications
but now we brought it out so that people
can use it externally as well
and the workflow that's built into it
has really been driven
uh by a lot of the engagements that we
have had with customers that are
building
machine learning models at scale and
booted them into very high scale
production
applications lots of things in this that
i don't have time to talk about today
things like
being able to use notebooks um automated
machine learning being able to just give
it a data set and it tries a bunch of
models
there's a nice drag-and-drop visual
interface that i can't go in today
but instead i'm going to focus on
these concepts these abstractions
which help us build a nice process for
machine learning operations
things like data sets being able to
aversion
a set of rows and columns of data and
being able to get back to that version
of data at any time
in a reproducible way when we want to
recreate our models and our experiments
experiments in this context are training
runs a model
uh i'm thinking of a statistical model
here that we would try against a
specific version of data
and the metrics like accuracy that we
get back from that model being able to
track all of those
um pipelines aren't going to cover too
much here but being able to combine
together
little pieces of our code little pieces
of python code that together form a
complete workflow
we might want to execute as part of a
continuous integration or continuous
delivery process
models we're all familiar with the
concept of a model with us from a
statistical standpoint
but a framework that allows us to
register models that we might want to
use and have versions associated with
those models
and endpoints this is where the ops part
of it comes in
a real-time endpoints that we can use to
pass data to those models and get
results back think predictions for
models
and also endpoints for those pipelines
that i mentioned just a minute ago
so that we can automate the process of
kicking off sequences
of doing computations in r and do that
as part of a larger build process for a
complete application
the last three on this list are more
like infrastructure that we need to
manage to help us do part of the
do all of this process uh the first of
those is compute
managed computing resources that we use
for doing our interactive
experimentation
the resources that we use to build our
large models and the resources that we
use to deploy those large models into
applications the environments i
mentioned briefly already
the computing environment that's needed
to do all this reproducibly
and then data stores think here of the
databases or the blob stores
where the fundamental data files that
represent those data sets
exist
what i'm going to be using in this talk
today is
a relatively new package for r it's
available now on cran called
azure ml sdk which provides a suite of
our functions for doing
and working with all those artifacts
that i just told you about
so there are functions for creating
workspaces and experiments and computing
models and so forth
all this works with any modern version
of art it's not specific to microsoft at
all
um you can use any our package a github
package a private package it's all
completely open in that sense
um and it tracks all those associated
requirements like the packages that
you're using with your code
so that it can follow that through to
make sure those packages are available
at deployment time a few other things i
don't have time to talk about are things
like hyperdrive support which is mainly
used in machine language
machine learning for trying lots of
different hyper parameters around models
but we are going to look at publishing
an r based model as a web service
i'm going to do it into azure but you
can also do it into your own servers as
well in exactly the same way
and we're also briefly going to talk
about triggering these processes from
ci cd pipelines as we're building
applications
around r so i'm going to show you a
little example this is based on some
data from the u.s traffic service
around fertility fatalities in auto
accidents and i want to build a model
that predicts the probability of a
fatality given the types of variables
you can see there on the right
but the process is going to be a pretty
traditional machine learning process
i'm going to import some data and
prepare it and then i'm going to build a
model and to do that i need a cluster of
machines
to train that model and in fact i'm
going to do some glm k n
and glm net models from carrot
then we're going to have a look at the
results of those models and select the
best one according to accuracy
and then deploy an r function that
predicts from that model
as a container and that container is
then going to expose an
endpoint which we could call from any
application but i'm going to
demonstrate that here with a shiny
application
so let me show you how that works um the
first thing i need to do is to create
a compute instance which is the little
machine in the cloud that i can use for
my interactive work
so here's an example where i've created
um an rstudio compute instance
um this is a standard ds2v2 virtual
machine which is basically a two-core
machine with about seven gigs of ram
a bit better than my laptop but not much
but the nice thing is it has persistent
storage and i can share that with other
people
and i can just launch an r studio server
instance on that directly
and use that on the cloud if i need a
beefier machine
i could launch a gpu based instance like
this one here which has a little level
of 50 gigabytes of ram
and six processors so you can just get a
machine if you need a more powerful
machine just to do your experimentation
it's really easy to spin one up
or you can just use your own laptop um
with all this
azure machine learning service that i'm
talking about you can just use all your
own infrastructure for all the levels of
this
or you can use the azure cloud-based
services if you want as well
so here's some r code all this is
available in the github repository which
is linked
on the bottom left-hand corner of the
screen right there
so here's an example of me creating a
compute instance which i'm going to use
to sorry within the compute instance
some code that i'm doing to just import
a regular csv file
do some preparation and then store that
data object our data object into a
shared
storage service so that will be
available when i do my training runs
in just a moment
here is some r code um create aml
compute that's creating a cluster for me
in the cloud which i'm gonna use to do
all of my training runs
uh this is a fairly small cluster i've
defined it to be a minimum nodes one
and maximum nodes two that means one
node is always live which means it's
always quick for me to submit
jobs into that cluster everything
something's always ready to go
you can set that minimum nodes to zero
and it will automatically scale down to
nothing
when you're not using it so you're not
paying for any compute at that time
and another thing you can do is use
something called low priority
azure virtual machines which gives you
about an 80 discount on the regular
virtual machine costs at the possible
expense of them being shut down
unexpectedly
but the service will pick that up and
just resubmit the job anyway
so now that we have our compute
environment ready to go
let's try training some models so we can
have a look at some results and choose
one to deploy
here's an example of submitting some r
code to that cluster and you can see
it's pretty simple
all i need to do is define an r script
file here's where it's called
accident glmnet.r which is some pretty
standard carrot code
which imports that same data that i
stored to the shared data store
does a train call and then saves the
resulting model object
back to the data store again and that
submit experiment
command you see right there at the
bottom cues up that job on the cluster
it'll wait until it is available and
then run that r code
and save all the results for me if you
need to work
um you can also modify the behavior of
these scripts as well with
command line parameters you can see one
option i have there is percent train to
define the test versus train proportion
uh in the actual modeling so you have a
lot of control of how those run as well
the actual environment where r runs
in that cluster is actually pre-loaded
with just about every package on cran
for you
but if you want to have a github package
or a private package it's easy to have
that done in there as well
it tracks all the results so i can
always go back and have a look at all of
the results
on the top right hand side we can see
the accuracy from all these models
and then pick one of those that's the
best to deploy
to deploy it the first thing i need to
do is register that model in the system
uh that registered with a version so
this is where the versioning of the
models comes in
the r script that runs through the
actual prediction
gets the data which is a json object so
you just need to decompile it into json
and then just use regular r code
to do the prediction model right there
and then finally we can deploy that
model as a service
um you can see the deploy model function
right there which takes the model that
we just registered
along with its r code and then that
becomes a live container
this in this case in azure container
instances which exposes a rest endpoint
which i can send data to
the container runs the r code sends the
prediction
back for me so let's actually have a
look at that in action
within a shiny application and again all
this code is available to you
which i'll show you real quickly
here is the arco this is running on my
local laptop right here right now
but when i run the shiny application
hopefully the internet is working here
there we go so this is the prediction
based on all these variables if i
increase the occupant
of the car's age and particularly the
impact speed of the accident
you can see the probability the accident
gets much higher
that calculation is being done within
that inference cluster that i created in
the cloud
and i'm doing in this case from shiny
and r but you could do that from any
application
you like calling out directly to that
rest endpoint
and that's kind of where the next stage
comes into i don't have time to go into
all the details of this
but if you're using a ci cd service like
azure pipelines or github actions
you can control all those processes
through the command line interface
that's provided with azure machine
learning service
and if you're using azure pipelines
which is part of azure devops
there is a plug-in that makes it really
easy to do things like
when i as a data scientist
register a new model into the system
a ci cicd process is immediately kicked
off within azure devops to build
the entire application around that new
model and then deploy that into
production
i've got a link to a talk that i've
given there i'm an ai ml50 repo that
shows that entire process
it's about using python to deploy a
vision model into website application
but all those same principles
apply equally to r as well
so just to summarize what we just did is
built a pipeline and natural machine
learning service to prepare data train a
model then register that
into the into the service and then we
have a ci cd pipeline in azure devops
which then takes that model recognizes
when that model is registered
deploys it as a container instance a
single container for testing
typically then we do some testing on
that container before going to
production
and then to production we would then
deploy that same model to a cluster like
kubernetes
for a production level facility for
uh integrating that model into your
application and because you've got that
pipeline set up it's really easy to do
things like
retraining your model for example if
after a certain amount of time or
perhaps after reviewing the metrics from
your live model
you want to retrain it you can just kick
off those same pipelines
to update your model completely
automatically
so all the information you need about
azure pipelines and the azure machine
learning service is available at those
links
right there and those links are also
available at the repository that i've
put up
for this talk at the link you see on
your screen right there thank you very
much
[Applause]
thank you david we have uh time for one
question sure
uh are there existing options for
authenticating with devops from
our studio server pro if not is it
something that will be coming
um in fact that's what i did within
our studio server not even the pro
version all the authentication happens
directly
uh within the r package itself for
example when you first try and register
a workspace it pops up a little prompt
for you to authenticate directly with
azure active directory through a web
page that already exists
great thanks so much thank you